you take a year off your way and you
come back and you are surrounded by
nothing but open love and hugs and open
arms how's that feel man it's
emotionally it's it's a rollercoaster
venting and I'm I think you know life
sort of teaches you these hard lessons
sometimes and part of that lesson is
that it allowed me to really have
perspective and to really enjoy fact
that he chose to be with his family and
then he's here and with his family and
and is know was doing really well you
know we're all so thankful we've seen
him go through a lot of stuff this last
couple of years so we've all been
cheering for him it's our musical family
it's emotional for me it's really quite
lovely and I you know I listen you know
there's gonna be ups and downs and stuff
but I feel a huge sense of pride because
I love my country and that pride was
never more evident than during the
moving tribute to the late Gor Downey
[Music]
Gords brothers accepted his Juno for
artist of the year after he picked up
two wins the night before for songwriter
and adult alternative album of the year
I Love You Gordon
back in 2005 Gordon The Tragically Hip
were inducted into the Canadian Music
Hall of Fame and last night another one
of Canada's best barenaked ladies join
that illustrious list
people are talking they're saying that
you're putting the old band back
together
well at least for one night
[Applause]
it feels also like maybe like some kind
of premise for a Wes Anderson movie it's
a little surreal yeah I feel and of
course I'm the Owen Wilson character who
has to go around apologizing to
everybody what does it mean to be back
on stage tonight with your old pal it's
been really great sort of rehearsing
already you know we feel that that
groove come back immediately so that's
been really refreshing it's good to see
him after all this time jesse reyes was
the only woman who run on the TV
broadcast of this year's Juno's exactly
like alessia cara at the Grammys during
the show and on the red carpet Buffy
sainte-marie pushed for gender equality
in the business and safety the music
industry has to be safer for women we
don't talk about it a lot but it's not
yet safe but we're getting there and
with stars like Jesse leading a new
generation of musicians as this year's
breakthrough artists the future is
female and for her this is just the
start there's a farm for my father
there's a lot of things I suppose that I
get done so the reality is not bigger
than the dream yet hopefully one day
what it's not there yet